this is the message that I always hear
from you and this is you as a friend
this is the you that I understand but
this is not how you're commonly
represented you are the most
misrepresented person I've ever met in
my life I have never seen someone who
has so much positive that gets ignored
and where people are looking for any
little thing that they could possibly
misrepresent and switch up and change
and I'm kind of stunned by it I mean I'm
really not sure what it is about you
that's so polarizing with all these
different people that are deciding that
you are some sexist transphobic evil
person that's this right-wing all right
the figure you know even to the point
where it's it's it's kind of humorous to
me sometimes when I read some of these
these takes on you what do you think
that's from like what what is have you
this is a new thing for you you mean
that's only been the last few years that
you've gone from this relatively unknown
professor in a university in Toronto to
being this worldwide figure where people
you're obviously your message is
resonating with people in a very huge
way but the people that are opposing you
they're vehemently opposed what do you
think that is collective don't like me
collectivists what do you mean by that
people who think the probably proper
unit of analysis in the world is a
political and B group oriented the
identity politics types don't like me at
all and they have every reason not to
because I'm not I'm not a fan of
identity politics
I think things that's why you're
misrepresented but fundamentally there's
other reasons I mean I came out against
this bill in Canada bill C 16 that that
hypothetically purported to do nothing
else but to increase the the domain of
Rights that were applied to transsexual
people but there was a there was plenty
more to that bill man let me tell you
and I read the Paul
see don't the policies that went along
with it and it was a compelled speech
bill and so I opposed it on the grounds
that the politicians are not supposed to
leap out of their proper domain and
start to compel speech it's not the same
as forbidding hate speech I'm I think
hate speech should be left the hell
alone personally for all sorts of
reasons but to compel the contents of
speech is a whole new thing it's never
been done before in the history of
British common law English common law
and it's actually the Supreme Court in
the 1940s in the u.s. said that that was
not to be allowed and so it's a major
transgression and they said while we're
doing it for all the right reasons it's
like no no you don't get it you don't
get to compel speech I don't care what
your reasons are and why should I trust
your damn reasons anyways what makes you
so saint like so that you can violate
this fundamental principle and I should
assume that you're doing it for nothing
but compassion and that you're wise
enough to manage that properly it's like
sorry no I read your policies I see what
you're up to I don't like the
collectivists I think they're
unbelievably dangerous and I have reason
to believe that so I think that when
push comes to shove if your unit of
analysis is the group and your worldview
is one group and its power claims
against all other groups that that
that's not acceptable
it's it's tribalism of the worst form
and it'll lead to nothing but mayhem and
disaster and part of the reason you're
doing it isn't because your compassion
it's because you're envious and you
don't want to take responsibility for
your own life and I'm calling you on it
and so you don't like me so I must be an
alright figure I must be a Nazi saying
your house needs a lot of work man
there's a lot of rot in the in the
floorboards the plumbing is leaking the
water's coming in you're not you're not
the sage and st. you think you are
there's so much work you have to do on
yourself that it would damn near kill
you to take a look at it we do
everything honestly think that that's
why people are responding to you in a
negative way that they only have their
own personal problems that they're
avoiding it can't possibly be that you
represent to them something that is
either cruel or something that is not
compassionate about people and their
differences and their flaws and their
their humanity because I think it's
certainly the case that they're the
vision
let's be generated of me is yes that's
what I'm getting at oh yeah there's that
too but why is layers say there's well
part of its the political polarization
you know at the moment we're viewing
almost everything that happens in the
world through a political lens at least
the journalists at least first of all
first of all I gotta make this clear
first of all I've been treated well by
lots of journalists really well like the
best journalists in Canada have been on
my side since about two weeks after the
bill c16 thing erupted and those would
be the journalists that have an
independent voice and that are that that
have created their own following and
they're in a number of different media
places mostly in print okay and there's
a there's a coalition of newspapers in
Canada the post media group 200
newspapers they came out fully in
support of my stance on on Bill c60 and
so there's lots of times that I've been
treated properly by journalists there's
a small number of journalists very noisy
and a small number of activists very
well organized who've been on my case
right from the beginning and those are
people who are generally driven by a
very radical leftist progressive agenda
and I am not on their side I'm on their
side as individuals I'm on their side as
people who could struggle forward but
the collectivist vision it's deadly but
you seem to be the poster boy for this
very simple characterization like almost
a caricature of what the the the
alt-right figurehead is it's and it's to
me as a person who knows you it's very
strange to watch this take place